do not and I cannot emphasize this
enough make deep fakes of Taylor Swift
it's not going to end well for you
Taylor Swift has made legal history
before punishing the people who have
crossed her on January 25th deep fake
nude images of Swift started circulating
on Twitter the images were apparently
created in a telegram group dedicated to
making AI images of women when Twitter
finally acted to remove the images they
had been viewed at least 45 million
times the company had to throttle
searches for Swift's own name to shut it
all down great moderation system you got
there Elon but does she have a legal
remedy well there's no federal law
against deep fakes but Taylor could use
Tor law to file a lawsuit against the
people who created the images in Most
states most states recognize some form
of right to publicity and likeness in
New York the state's R of publicity law
now includes protection against digital
replicas of deceased celebrities and
obscene deep fake images California's R
of publicity statute requires permission
to use someone's name voice signature
photograph or likeness on products or an
advertising and she could sue for
invasion of privacy and emotional
distress which reminds me if you're out
there Taylor if you need a great lawyer
my firm the eagle team can take care of
it just click below